[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60 18 26 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
ce mercredi 22 janvier inauguré en 1975
le lycée franco-allemand de but qui est
entré dans une phase de réhabilitation
et d'extension ce matin le département
des yvelines et la région ile-de-france
ont posé symboliquement la première
pierre du chantier qui devrait se
poursuivre pendant deux ans elle est née
officiellement au 1er janvier 2020
l'université paris saclay se donne
l'objectif de devenir le numéro 1
français élu vs qu y siègent pour le
moment comme universités membres avant
une fusion totale en 2025
quelle place aura t-elle dans la
gouvernance éléments de réponse enfin au
chapitre des élections municipales à les
candidates à villepreux valérie bains
sera à la tête d' agir avec vous pour
villepreux une liste qui se veut
citoyenne et participative le début de
ce journal avec l'information du jour
[Musique]
le lycée franco allemand de buc aura
bientôt un nouveau visage ce matin la
région ile de france le département des
yvelines et l'académie de versailles se
rassembler pour poser symboliquement la
première pierre du chantier
l établissement connaît est important
d'importants travaux de rénovation
depuis le mois de septembre 2019 mélanie
poker une première pierre symbolique le
22 janvier 1963 était signé le traité de
l'élysée donnant naissance en 1975 au
lycée franco-allemand qui connaît
aujourd'hui une rénovation complète des
travaux d'un montant de 56 millions
d'euros pris en charge par la région et
le département la région veut des lycées
campus aujourd'hui très tourné vers
l'enseignement supérieur la préparation
de la vie professionnelle et et tout ça
évidemment ça conduit à débit licence ça
conduit à des études supérieures de
lettres le département des yvelines avec
la région ile de france voulait
véritablement aboutir
jusqu'au moment où le département a pris
la décision de faire parce que
la région disait oui mais ne nous
accompagner pas jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait
la volonté de valérie pécresse qui vient
de s'exprimer
soixante neuf salles d'enseignement plus
de douze mille mètres carrés un gymnase
et un plateau sportif ouvert au public
accueillant aujourd'hui près de 900
élèves le lycée pourra recevoir jusqu'à
1300 jeunes il ya une liste d'attenté
alors c'est peut-être lié au fait qu'il
n'y a qu'un seul établissement en france
aujourd'hui et où on essaye de venir ici
sur un enseignement de qualité mais
portait sur une culture internationale
et sur un cursus qui permet aux élèves
d'aller très facilement ensuite faire
leurs études à l'étranger
l'anglais est aujourd'hui c'est comme
les mathématiques il faut le savoir
l'allemand est un vrai atout en plus et
ça les gens se rend compte que ça
l'aurait sur les aide dans leur dans
leur avenir personnel professionnel
culturel
les premiers pas des élèves dans leurs
nouveaux locaux devraient se faire pour
la rentrée 2021
la dernière phase des travaux est prévue
pour le 31 mars 2022
quasiment au même moment une
cinquantaine d'enseignants s'est donné
rendez vous devant les locaux de
l'académie de versailles
une mobilisation dans le cadre de la
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites et aussi contre le nouveau
baccalauréat et les professeurs ont
déposé devant les grilles du rectorat
des livres et cahiers et ont affiché
plusieurs faux chèques d'un montant de
50 mille euros les explications au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude à chaque
fin d'année les recteurs et les
directeur académique de l'éducation
nationale reçoivent une prime de 50
mille euros alors c'est sûr que ça
favorise d'autant plus
le système de retraite dorée forme à
point en ce qui concerne les enseignants
ils ont très peu de prix mais c'est
aussi pour ça qu'ils sont qui vont être
massacrés par cette réforme
les enseignants qui seront dans le
cortège interprofessionnel demain jeudi
à versailles manifestation qui partira
depuis la gare des chantiers pour se
rendre sur la place d'armes devant les
grilles du château de versailles
l académie de versailles justement a
présenté la semaine dernière un plan de
prévention des violences pour un climat
scolaire apaisée dans les communes de
saint quentin en yvelines la prévention
face au harcèlement scolaire et à
l'isolément des jeunes étaient déjà
active
reportage à plaisir et aussi à montigny
le bretonneux avec marylène iapichino et
jacques brun un enfant sur dix est
victime de harcèlement scolaire
en plus de faire preuve de vigilance il
est nécessaire de faire de la prévention
dans les cours de récréation des écoles
élémentaires de plaisir des banques bien
identifiables ont fait leur apparition
au mois de décembre
j'ai une dispute qui était m'asseoir sur
le banc puis après y'a quelqu'un qui est
venu pour qu'on joue ensemble car ce
banc vert est un bond de l'amitié
inspiré par une école privée du
département la ville de plaisir a
souhaité l'installer dans toutes ses
écoles le fait d'avoir à bancs de la bi
tié ça permet à des enfants d'avoir un
lieu repères pour se positionner pour
s'y asseoir et faire comprendre aux
autres sans forcément le verbaliser
qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
plus que le harcèlement ce bond est un
outil de lutte contre l'isolément dont
les enfants se sont déjà saisies
la demande de ce bord avait même été
faite par un jeune de cet établissement
scolaire il ya quelques années pour les
collégiens de montigny le bretonneux
tapis
la prévention passe aussi par le théâtre
la ville a établi un partenariat avec
les établissements depuis une dizaine
d'années ils suivent des ateliers sur le
bien vivre ensemble tout au long de leur
scolarité
la séance de débat théâtral intervient
une fois par an pour les classes de 4e
les équipes enseignantes non le dise
aujourd'hui qu'en fait les jeunes
viennent plus parler ce pas forcément
les jeunes qui sont victimes mais voilà
les amis l'entourage ils vont aller plus
par les verts le ver l'adulte ils ont un
peu plus conscience des personnes
référentes autour d'eux au programme
quatre scènes représentant des
situations de harcèlement
les adolescents sont ensuite invités à
monter sur scène pour entrer dans la
peau d'un personnage et corriger les
comportements des adultes encadrant les
établissements nous disent comme un
petit miracle parce qu'ils voient leurs
élèves d'une manière différente
finalement est-ce que les élèves
viennent pas à faire passer leur message
à travers des personnages
la magie opère les jeunes improvisent
avec les comédiens et trouver les
solutions pour éviter les situations de
harcèlement de la mise à l'écart à cause
d'un physique ou d'une tenue
vestimentaire au cyber harcèlement
toutes les thématiques sont abordées
j'ai bossé avec avec kenza
elle se faisait harceler allait se faire
agresser et gelé défendu une fois le
spectacle terminé les enseignants sont
amenés à poursuivre le travail
objectif amener les jeunes à parler et
pour parler signaler des faits de
harcèlement scolaire un numéro d'appel
existe un numéro d' écoute c'est le 30
20 elle est née officiellement au 1er
janvier 2020 à l'université paris saclay
créé par décret en novembre est entrée
en vigueur depuis le début de l'année
l'ambition pour cette grosse université
devenir la première française est aussi
entré dans le top 20 mondial
on parle de cette actualité avec alain
buis bonsoir bonsoir lettre le président
de l'uds vs qq vs cuite il fait partie
des sept établissements qui composent
cette université paris saclay je
rappelle qu'au sein de cette grande
université il y a trois universités donc
lu vs qu l'université paris-sud
l'université d'evry quatre grandes
écoles et aussi des organismes de
recherche lu vs cul qui a changé son
identité visuelle tout récemment
l'intégrant le logo de paris-saclay ça
veut dire que le processus de fusion va
en parler dans un instant il est
totalement dans ses puits est totalement
lancé il est irréversible et révocable
et il sera bénéfique pour l'université
pour le territoire également et c'est
une fusion donc il va être progressive
en 2025 on en parle juste après mais des
diplômes étaient déjà estampillée
paris-saclay était déjà délivré par
l'université paris saclay ce là la
création de l'établissement qu'on avait
établissement expérimental université
paris saclay qui manoeuvrait universités
dans laquelle lu vs qu a été tout au
long a construit co-construit est
l'aboutissement finalement de plusieurs
années de synergies et de collaboration
qui a eu entre les différents
partenaires élus vs qi vêtement est déjà
largement engagé dans cette université
et donc il y a
beaucoup de nos diplômes surtout nos
diplômes de master 80% nos diplômes de
master et la totalité des diplômes de
doctorat qui sont déjà mutualiser et ses
enseignements au lieu ces formations ont
lieu sur notre sur le territoire sur nos
campus et qui sont délivrés par arnaud
d'autres enseignants donc on précisé à
ce jour que parmi les trois universités
qui composent à l'université paris c'est
que la seule université paris sud a
fusionné totalement au 1er janvier du
véhicule ce sera en 2025
à ce jour l'université un statut de
membre associé concrètement qu'est ce
que ça veut dire dans la gouvernance
quelle place a lu vs qu au sein de cette
université paris saclay alors au bien
comprendre un processus de fusion
d'université c'est un processus
opérationnels qui complexent donc ils
nécessitent du temps et donc c'est ces
cinq ans qui sont à venir sont
nécessaires et sont indispensables pour
opérer cette fusion et malgré cela
l'université comme joue lady elle a
toujours été actrice dunières c'est
pareil simplet et elle appartient à
l'université paris saclay et ce jean
veut pour preuve et ça c'est le ce
sentiment d'appartenance et qu' il y a
actuellement il va y avoir la semaine
prochaine des élections des instances de
gouvernance de l'université paris saclay
et pour lesquelles tous les personnels
sans exception de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin divine vont
être électeur et éligible dans ces
instants cela nous espérer que ses
membres de l'ue est ce qu on déplace on
va dire des bonnes places au sein de
cette université paris 7 ex ils soient
bien représentées au sein de cette
grosse université
j'ai la conviction qu'ils en auront
parce que c'est notre université c'est
leur université
aussi alors l'ambition je le disais
c'est de devenir la première université
française de figurer dans les
classements mondiaux est ce que d'après
vous c'est un objectif réaliste on
précise que cette université à terme
regroupera 80 mille étudiants plus de
dix mille enseignants chercheurs c'est
un objectif réaliste de deux y est on va
on va être la première université
française c'est si vous laissez plus que
réaliste je pense que c'est une réalité
en tout cas la première sinon pas très
loin donc ça et on a déjà évidemment on
construit ce projet on a on savait déjà
que honoré
ses dimensions à la fois internationale
d'être dans le top 20 des universités
dans dans leur mondial
et puis on avance et on les a quantifié
les forces pour être la première
si on vient juste sur la date de 2025 ça
veut dire que le ps qui aura totalement
disparu sera fondue dans cette
université paris saclay où elle sera
fondu mais elle ne va pas disparaître ce
qui faisait l'existence de levier ce qui
ne va pas disparaître les campus vont
être renforcées et vont être on va
investir dans les campus
il sait campus vont devenir des campus
de l'université paris saclay au même
titre que les autres campus de
l'université
et quelle stratégie doit adopter à votre
avis l'université face à un autre pôle
qui s'est monté sur le plateau de saclay
au tour de l'institut polytechnique ça
s'appelle d'ailleurs l'institut
polytechnique ça regroupe polytechnique
hec d'autres grandes écoles est ce que
l'idée c'est d'être dans des trains aux
mollahs de la concurrence pardon ou dans
une stratégie de collaboration ceni de
la concurrence et de la collaboration
elle existe que je crois qu'on sadri on
s'adresse aussi à des publics différents
et que ce sont des objets qui se
regroupe des établissements qui se
regroupent et qui existait avant donc si
vous voulez la situation ne change pas
tout ce qui peut être globalement sur le
plateau de saclay qui puisse faire
valoriser au mieux la science française
au niveau mondial est une bonne chose
voilà pour l'université paris saclay on
suivra bien sûr l'évolution des choses
une autre actualité pour lui vs qu
l'université inauguré tout récemment le
cube c'est un espace pédagogique au sein
de la bibliothèque universitaire de
guyancourt comment ça fonctionne
concrètement et quels sont les objectifs
de cet espace alors c'était un projet
ambitieux qui marque bien c'est aussi
lié au projet paris saclay notre
stratégie est lié où on va mettre en
place de nouveaux
nouveau moyen de la pédagogie donc ça de
l'innovation pédagogique on utilise
également des moyens numériques et donc
c'est un projet qui a été co construit
avec l'université numérique ile de
france qui nous a soutenus et donc c'est
afin de créer un espace pour des
apprentissages pour changer les
apprentissages qui soit formelle ou
informelle les choses modulable et donc
qu'ils vont venir accompagner les
méthodes nouvelles méthodologies
d'enseignement qui se mettre
progressivement en place et qui sont
adaptés à notre temps merci alain lui je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
merci une dernière cérémonie de voeux
pour jean-luc ourgaud à montigny le
bretonneux c'était cette semaine à la
ferme du manet et le maire sortant et
qui ne se représentera pas a fait le
bilan de ses 25 années passées au
conseil municipal ces trois ans aussi en
tant que maire l'occasion de revenir sur
les projets qu'il a pu mener notamment
sur le forum des arts charles aznavour
le pôle petite enfance mais aussi le
club le village qui est en pleine
rénovation les propos collectées par
mathilde et demi je voudrais surtout
insisté sur la maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire et universitaire
c'est vraiment une belle innovation à
terme 17 à 18 praticiens donc c'est un
projet qui nous tenait à coeur depuis
trois quatre ans voilà il arrive là
maintenant
à la fin à sa réalisation en tout cas en
terme d'aménagement toujours à montigny
le bretonneux une nouveauté de 2020 pour
le centre commercial sqy ouest
à l'ouverture le 7 février prochain de
l'espace simulation highway cette
entreprise lyonnaise propose de conduire
et des voitures de course de se lancer
aussi dans une mission spatiale ou de
participer pourquoi pas un escape game
nicolas landry et jacques brun pour le
reportage piloter une formule 1 où une
voiture de rallye c'est l'expérience
proposée par l'espace de simulation
highway cette société lyonnais
s'installe dans le centre skywest avec
la possibilité de se lancer dans une
course avec six joueurs on va pendant
une quarantaine de minutes
commencez par vous équipez vous briefé
vous installer dans les voitures tout
l'intérêt c'est de faire vivre les
sensations que ressentent les pilotes
professionnels
cette activité innovante dans le secteur
du loisir s'accompagne d'une expérience
de réalité virtuelle collaborative avec
plusieurs histoires on a une mission qui
s'appelle iss rescue on vous envoie dans
l'espace pour une mission de routine
sauf que ça pas tout à fait se passer
comme ça aurait dû se passer vous allez
avoir 45 minutes vous allez être à 408
km au-dessus de la terre et vous allez
être en équipe pour essayer de
solutionner ce qui se passe on a une
autre et quand on s'appelle coopération
de lightspace on n'est plus dans la peau
d'un commando ayew et propose aussi des
scénarios des skins game classique une
entreprise déjà expérimentée elle a
ouvert son premier centre en 2008 à lyon
avec des prix variant de 25 à 99 euros
en fonction des activités notre modèle
économique il est véritablement bâti sur
une clientèle grand public une clientèle
entreprises aujourd'hui 50 ans et vince
est calme le deuxième pôle économique de
l'ouest parisien
donc sur cette partie entreprises
c'était une véritable valeur ajoutée
derrière ça reste un bassin de
population ou qui est dense ce nouveau
centre cible aussi la clientèle
parisienne objectif d ouais un chiffre
d'affaires prévisionnel de 2,5 millions
d'euros
l'ouverture est prévue le 7 février
prochain
[Musique]
la page dédiée aux élections municipales
pour terminer ce journal focus ce soir
sur la commune de villepreux est depuis
plusieurs week end la liste tous pour
villepreux mené par sylvie se vend 1
mantel a décidé d'aller à la rencontre
des habitants le 19 janvier l'équipe
s'est rendue dans le quartier de
rambouillet aurélie rond et michael et
demi d'euros c'est à l'extérieur que
sylvie ce vin montel tête de liste de
tous pour villepreux a choisi de mener
sa campagne
élu depuis 12 ans elle s'est entourée
d'une équipe représentant tous les
quartiers de la ville
voilà pourquoi elle a choisi ce mode
d'action pour aller à la rencontre des
habitants et ses balades urbaines
c'est très novateur concept ça ne s'est
jamais faire villepreux est donc
quasiment qu'une ville des yvelines à
part une ou deux et donc le concept de
dalé in situ sur le terrain des horaires
précis à la rencontre des villes procédé
divine croisien ça a vraiment du sens et
est bien passé gentil monsieur c'est une
bonne idée si tu sens l'occasion de
donner des des idées sur les les
améliorations apportées dans le quartier
parmi les grands thèmes du programme de
sylvie ce vent montait la sécurité le
cadre de vie le développement durable et
la proximité avec les élus sur les
charmants petits footings la baraque en
marchant forcé et puis je les rencontre
et elle a une grande expérience souci de
la ville je pense que certains d'évacuer
tous pour villepreux est une liste sans
étiquette et ne bénéficient pas de
soutien de partis politiques
nous voulons être libres on veut pas que
dans deux ans trois ans nous disent
écoutez on vous a aidé en 2020 voilà
vous nous renvoyer l'ascenseur d'autres
balades urbaines sont prévus le week-end
du 25 janvier les
de tous pour villepreux se rendra
notamment cartier du vieux village et du
prieuré ainsi que dans le quartier du
val joyeux une autre liste sans
étiquette pour ces élections municipales
à villepreux celle menée par vous
valérie ben bon soir enfin vous êtes la
tête de liste d'agir avec vous pour vil
prix une liste qui se veut citoyenne
ouverte et participative et c'est une
liste qui regroupe des habitants des
commerçants des acteurs du secteur
associatif mais aussi deux conseillers
municipaux actuels d'opposition l'idée
c'est que ce soit une candidature
plurielle qui unissent les forces
finalement oui alors la liste elle s'est
d'abord créé sur les projets
effectivement nos idées ont attiré des
gens qui étaient de tous les milieux de
tous les environs de tous les quartiers
donc voilà comment ça s'est passé
c'est un processus qui remonte à un an
cette constitution de listes
on a commencé effectivement bon tout est
parti du projet central park de la phase
de pseudo concertation qui a été
organisée et voilà petit à petit on
s'est regroupé les uns avec les autres
et on s'est aperçu que au delà du projet
central park y avait d'autres projets
sur lesquels on pouvait proposer une
alternative à ce que nous donnait la
majorité de l'époque on parlera tout à
l'heure de ce projet central park
vous êtes à titre personnel valérie bain
un soutien de la république en marché ce
que ça ça ne rentrent pas en ligne de
compte dans cette liste il ya aucune
investiture qui est revendiquée oui
alors donc moi je dirige un collectif en
fait et ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
projets au niveau de la municipalité ces
projets là on parle de sécurité on parle
de santé on parle d'urbanisme ça va
au-delà en fait des étiquettes
politiques
donc je dirige une liste citoyenne
ouverte et plurielle et voilà il n'y a
pas d'autre il n'y a pas de soutien ni
de loin ni de près sur notre liste
citoyenne
il ya un autre angle affiché aussi dans
cette candidature c'est de promouvoir la
démocratie participative
comment vous verriez les habitants
davantage associés à la décision
communale est ce que ce peut-être au
travers par exemple de budgets
participatifs comme on peut voir fleurir
sur d'autres communes comment comment
vous voyez les choses alors ben là on
voit en période d'élection que tout le
monde va à la rencontre des villes pro
dit un autre
sont extrêmement sollicités on leur
demande leur avis et c'est donc là
l'idée c'est d'avoir cette dynamique
mais tout au long du mandat de
communiquer sur les propositions et puis
donc d'aider les villes provient qui le
souhaitent à monter des projets avec
l'appui de l'équipe municipale allait
présenter en fait à la municipalit enfin
aux habitants de villepreux qui
eux-mêmes définiront les priorités
puisque effectivement on ne pourra pas
tout faire en même temps
et effectivement en fonction des projets
s'il ya des projets qui n'ont pas besoin
de financement et s'il ya des besoins
des projets qui ont besoin de
financement
il y aura une partie du budget qui sera
soutenue mais ça ce sont les villes
provient qui arbitreront entre les
projets et au niveau des enveloppes
budgétaires
non juste avant de parler de vos
priorités votre regard quel regard vous
portez sur les deux ans et les deux
mandats pendant les deux mandats
effectués par le maire stéphanie rambaud
qui y est donc
maire depuis 2008 écoutez il ya il ya
des choses qui sont bien qu'ils ont
avancés comme au niveau national il ya
beaucoup de konin qui ont qui ont avancé
sur justement les pesticides sur le les
cantines bio fin voilà donc tout ça
c'est des choses qui sont favorables à
la population après nous le problème
qu'on assure villepreux c'est la
multiplication des programmes
immobiliers dont on ne voit vraiment pas
le sens il est ça on n'arrive pas à
comprendre ou veut nous emmener cette
municipalité via le programme central
park notamment que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure un écoquartier de 19 mille
mètres carrés dans le secteur du trianon
et de l'ex rda 298 ça c'est un projet
que vous voulez je les en tout cas c'est
l'une de vos promesses si vous êtes élu
pourquoi il faut il faut l'arrêter
aujourd'hui ce projet en fait là on
vient d'avoir un quartier qui s'appelle
les eaux du moulin avec une première
tranche de à peu près 500 logements
on attend une deuxième tranche de 500
logements donc on arrive déjà à 1000
logements à intégrer dans ce quartier là
on our propose à nouveau
250 logements dans cet espace de verdure
en nous expliquant qu'en mettant des
bâtiments on va augmenter l'espace vert
donc pour nous là on est dans une crise
de croissance au niveau de la ville il
faut déjà qu'on absorbe en fait les
nouveaux arrivants de villepreux qui
sont les bienvenus conte
leur fasse partager notre qualité de vie
et nos valeurs et après on pourra
réfléchir à est-ce qu'on a encore
vraiment besoin de transformer ces
espaces verts en immeuble ça a l'air
d'aller un peu à contre sens en fait
avec ce que demandent les villes
provient précise tout de même que la loi
impose un quota de 25 % de logements
sociaux à l'horizon 2025 aujourd'hui
villepreux et aux alentours des 20 % les
communes qui ne respectent pas ces
rythme de construction se voit infliger
des pénalités comment on compose avec
cette contrainte imposée par l'état est
aussi respecté la transition écologique
voilà comment on a dit tout ça et
comment on respecte ses contraintes de
l'état
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
fini assez paradoxal mais quand vous
construisez sans logement et que du coup
vous vous faites 25 logements sociaux et
bien comme au total vous avez augmenté
le nombre de logements vous quelque part
vous le pourcentage que vous gagnez
minimes en fait donc la seule façon
c'est d'eux que nous on envisage c'est
de construire de toutes petites unités
mais uniquement de par exemple dix
logements sociaux voilà cent pour cent
logements sociaux sur dix logements
ça fait plus de bénéfices en fait que de
construire 25 % de logements sur une
unité de 80 c'est une alternative à ce
qui est proposé actuellement l'une de
vos priorités également c'est l'offre
culturelle vous souhaitez donner un
nouveau souffle aux théâtres de villes
prusse un équipement de 430 places quel
est le problème avec ce sex avec ce lieu
et je ne sais pas quel est le problème
en tous les cas la municipalité actuelle
avait accès énormément ses
investissements sur le sport et sert à
la culture était
la panne est mis de côté elle a été
ignorée pendant deux mandats donc voila
nous on a intégré la sky depuis 2016
on voit bien que les offres culturelles
sont organisées et on se dit qu'avec ce
magnifique théâtre de 430 places
on doit pouvoir faire quelque chose il
faut davantage travailler sur ce sujet
avec la la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
oui bah c'est absolument une ressource
pour nous en fait cette communauté
d'agglo voilà la vocation c'est de faire
des économies d'échelle de mutualiser
des moyens donc nous on veut absolument
aller dans ce sens là pour l'ensemble
des sujets qui concernent la
municipalité et la communauté d'agglo
mais en particulier pour la culture
mais justement villepreux fait partie de
l'agglomération depuis 2016 quel regard
vous portez sur le travail mené au sein
de cette agglomération sur la place
aussi de villepreux occupe dans cette
agglomération je précise que la commune
et est plutôt bien représentée avec le
maire stephen vieux mirambeau qui a une
vice-présidence aux finances est
également sylvie se démantèle un qui a
une délégation à l'école innovante est
la modernisation pédagogique quelle
quelle place enfin quel regard vous
portez sur cette place de villepreux
écouter sur ces sujets là qui sont
traités forcément il avance avec les
autres mais d'une façon générale nous
dans le cadre de la préparation de cette
campagne tous les experts qu'on
sollicite au niveau de la sky news
terrain on s'aperçoit que finalement il
ya des compétences à la sky et que l on
peu accès en fait aux villes provient
donc je pense que le rôle de la
municipalité par exemple pour la
rénovation énergétique
il faut que plus qu'on permette à ces
expertises qui sont au niveau de la sky
de diffuser leurs messages de d'en faire
bénéficier l'ensemble des villes proches
davantage de pédagogie expliquer les
compétences de l'agglomération
exactement faire du lien par exemple
l'école des eaux du moulin qui est
actuellement construite là une école de
16 classes elle est construite
uniquement par la municipalité sans le
soutien des équipes techniques de la sky
c'est quelque part une aberration
un dernier mot on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien votre prochain rendez vous de
campagne alors nous invitons tous les
villes provient à venir nous rejoindre à
notre réunion publique samedi prochain
25 janvier à 16h à la nex et puis pour
ceux qui ne pourraient pas venir il ya
une prochaine réunion qui aura lieu le
samedi 29 février aussi et enfin une
dernière réunion
le samedi 7 mars vous pouvez aussi nous
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux vous
venir à notre rencontre nous sommes
souvent présents sur le marché
merci valérie ben tête de liste d'agir
avec vous pour villepreux et outre votre
candidature et celle de sylvie souvent
mantel dont on parlait tout à l'heure la
candidature aux 6es du maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau celle du délégué
départemental du modem jean baptiste à
monique enfin kouros golgotha qui
conduira la liste tout simplement
villepreux voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi nouvelle
édition à retrouver demain jeudi sur
notre antenne belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]